Wow what are you changing a bit give him
a high-five just say lighten up buddy
lighten up buddy
I'm gonna in on a little secret about
Samuel is that not a lot of people no
he's actually a bit of a prankster he
loves playing practical jokes on
people's like integral of examples so a
couple years ago I had nine points on my
driving licence and Samuel knew this so
he sent me a letter as if I've got a
speeding ticket from the police and left
me thinking that I was banned and
driving for about four hours before he
finally told me that it was just a prank
he likes to ring the office and patan
funny accents he wearing me up the other
day about we lost a lot of money on card
machines he wanted me oh he just pranks
on me and the staff all the time so we
thought it was finally a chance
opportunity to get him back so he
explained to the plan
Samuels arriving at the crash course to
the night at about 8 p.m. and going on
stage there have been there all day with
our other trainers he's really need an
accession now here's the prank I'm gonna
go on stage before Samuel and get the
audience in on it it'd be a great chance
here at the crash course I wondered if
you guys wanted to help me in playing a
prank on Samuel would you guys like to
help me do that now Samuels here today
he's coming out on so he's actually
outside at the moment okay so he's
coming in in a minute he's gonna come
out on stage and Arlen's gonna give him
a really big build up he's gonna come
out and he knows you guys go crazy and
now if you ever seen some he's quite
energetic presents a he likes to get
feedback from the audience they'll
probably ask you a question it probably
say something like how many of you here
cuz you'll be fine actually free that's
it perfect okay so finally the
pranksters gonna be got back so are you
ready Annan to introduce him I'm gonna
get Emilia's in on it Emilio light works
summer so I'm gonna go and get her to
get him inside
okay you ready or I'll gonna get Samuel
thanks guys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
incredible successful businessman he is
a phenomenal property he's 17 he became
financially free she is young early
twenties
so ladies eternal please put your hands
together and welcome on stage the one
and only mr. Lee
good evenin how's the debut folks Wow
are we good have you guys found deals
today hon what have you been dealing
with these folks man okay geez serious
this is weird this is never ever happen
before I don't even know what to say has
anyone come from outside of England to
be here okay
so Wow what are you changing a be give
him a high five just say lighten up
buddy like not let it I'm having pranked
[Applause]
[Music]
that was the weirdest thing I was like I
was like I should have been here this
morning this is it on the Scrooge
someone screwed up
you got me has it been a good day oh my
goodness literally that right down I was
thinking I'm quitting training I'm not
I'm not crazy like today I spent the
whole day viewing houses I've been in
Liverpool you know and I was just like
I'm gonna get straight back to Vermont
forget this I'm over oh man
all right so how did how did you
orchestrate this did you have a hold on
sorry sorry did you have Amelia even in
on this where's Amelia I wish yeah yeah
millionaire oh my goodness I wondered
why they were like let's take you
outside she was getting me doing squats
and stuff I was like why are we doing
this oh my goodness all right so
[Music]
you